[Musique]
4e édition d'autres choses france lundi
28 janvier le sommet initié par le
président de la république a réuni près
de 150 dirigeants de grands groupes
étrangers et français faciliter la mise
en relation producteurs et consommateurs
la chambre d'agriculture d'ile-de-france
a lancé sa carte interactive où les
professionnels sont référencés en
fonction de leurs produits et de leur
localisation dans moins d'un mois ce
sont les jeux olympiques près de onze
mille athlètes vont se rassembler à
tokyo parmi eux plusieurs ebe noah qu'il
soit triathlète judokas cycliste ou
encore boxeur comme maiva hamadouche
boxeuse licence hier il encore
après les deux tours d'élections le
temps de l'installation ce 1er juillet
le conseil départemental a élu sa
présidence s'est sans surprise pierre
bédier qui reste à la tête de l'instance
12 vice-présidents aussi été nommé deux
ministres dans les yvelines jean castex
s'est rendu à jambville pour rencontrer
plus de 150 jeunes engagés dans un essai
news service national universel
jean baptiste djebbari était lui en
déplacement dans l'entreprise colas à
magny les hameaux
enfin le rapporteur public du conseil
d'état a demandé l'annulation des
élections municipales à trappes
mais sans requérir d'inégibilité pour le
maire génération ali rabais la décision
finale du conseil d'état sur la prise
d'ici deux à trois semaines
[Musique]